there's a special relationship between
the US and Israel and America sent giant
aircraft carriers to the
Mediterranean many of The Usual Suspects
have been rattling Sabers against Iran
uh there's been a lot of speculation
about Iran's involvement that is
still not nailed down but suffice it to
say the level that you know even though
that's undetermined at this moment it
has not stopped
the beat of the the war drums within the
GOP uh so I want to roll a montage of
Nikki Haley Mike Pence and Lindsey
Graham talking about the current
situation in
Iran President Joe Biden's cow Towing
for the last two and a half years to the
mulles in Iran lifting sanctions begging
them to get back in the Iran nuclear
deal and then uh paying $6 billion
dollar in a ransom uh for hostages I I
think set the conditions uh for this
unprecedented terrorist attack by Hamas
against Israel but I also believe this
is what happens when we have leading
voices like Donald Trump VC Ram Swami
and Ron Des santis signaling Retreat
from America's role as leader of the
Free World when they took these hostages
when they murdered these families they
were celebrating and what were they
celebrating they were saying death to
Israel death to America America this is
not just an attack on Israel this is an
attack on America because they hate us
just as much for every Israeli or
American hostage executed uh by Hamas we
should uh take down an Iranian oil
refinery the only way you're going to
keep this war from escalating is to hold
Iran
accountable so look
um Israel has a self-interest to respond
respond to this with great force for
Nikki Haley though to say that an attack
on Israel is an attack on America that
is you know it's an attack on Israel and
that that should be bad enough um and to
immediately start conflating those
interests and then for Lindsey Graham
to you know we have an interest in
getting us hostages back but to start
saying we should be bombing Iran's uh
oil refineries and just ratchet it up to
level 10 immediately Am I Wrong to view
this as really alarming
rhetoric I think that you're right to be
worried especially given the war on
terrorism and how voices just like these
led us so far astray and it was I don't
need to repeat to your audience but
going into Iraq was not just a human
Arian disaster for the Iraqis but
strategically idiotic for the United
States in terms of its counterterrorism
goals by taking out Saddam and enabling
you know Al-Qaeda and Iraq to to Really
flare up and over the years to to morph
into Isis um we need to be really
careful about um American missteps at a
time when you know in the immediate
aftermath of a terrorist um
tragedy um I also think that the media
has an important role to play in this
and even before we start talking about
policy prescription you know what should
the US response be we need to understand
what exactly
happened right I mean with 911 there was
a lot of false talk
lies about the role of Iraq um even
before we start thinking about what the
you know response should be if any to
Iran we do require more clarity into
precisely what Iran's role was and I
think that the media can do a really
good job of explaining to Citizens what
it is that we actually do know and what
our confidence level is in the things
that we say so for example what we do
know and this is again this precedes any
discussion about what the American
policy response if any should be it's
just as a basic factual matter here you
know what we do know for sure is that
Iran is a state sponsor of
terrorism if you of course include
Hezbollah and Hamas as terrorist groups
not everybody does but the state
department does and most academics do
certainly political scientists in North
America we we know that there's a
there's a level of Iranian support of
these groups they're not the same for
Hezbollah they have an even stronger
connection to Iran than Hamas does
Hezbollah was there at the very origin
of Hezbollah whereas Hamas is more of a
autonomous group that um I believe
essentially could have formed even
without um that even without Iranian
backing um it's not hard to imagine so
you don't need Iran to explain Hamas in
the same way that you need Iran to
explain Hezbollah which was part of
exporting the Iranian Revolution Etc um
so we know that there a certain level of
Baseline Iranian support of these groups
to various extent um there was a report
which we're kind of talking around which
came out of the Wall Street Journal
which suggests uh a much higher level of
direct Iranian
involvement um that they uh not only
were aware of the um operation but they
greenlighted it and it goes to the very
top of uh Iran and um these um terrorist
groups um some people if I could just
for just a second let me just read a
couple excerpts from that article you
referenced um around you know the the
headline uh which our viewers can see
but I'll read for our listeners Iran
helped plot attack on Israel Over
several weeks uh this was uh this came
out on October 8th uh Iranian security
officials helped plan hamas's Saturday
surprise attack according to senior
members of Hamas and
Hezbollah um us officials say they
haven't seen evidence of Ton's
involvement Secretary of State Anthony
blinkin said we have not seen yet seen
evidence that Iran directed or was
behind this particular attack but there
is certainly a long relationship there
was some subsequent reporting from
Newsweek which talked directly to some
Hamas Fighters or leadership uh they
said the Iranian or sorry it was the
Iranian mission to the United Nations
who they talked to told Newsweek that
Iran did not have a direct hand they say
we've supported Palestinian fighters in
acquiring fishing skills they
independently determine when where and
how to engage in fishing according to
their very own needs and interests so I
mean to to your point we just need to
tread carefully here and understand that
all parties involved are going to have
incentives to spin this one way or
another and um until things are I think
we we've learned from very recent
history that we need real confirmation
before kind of jump taking the next step
forward this is an extraordinarily
weighty
allegation and the more consequential
the
allegation um the more important it is
to to get the basic
facts right um I've heard people say
things like well look at the
sophistication of the attack like that's
like ifof facto you know evidence that
it must have been there must be um
Iranian involvement I mean I think
that's some of the strongest evidence is
that a Hamas leader um said I believe
that there was Iranian involvement but
honestly I I I was doing this same sort
of work um in 2003
and I was duped um about all sorts of
allegations about Iraq and and I said
that I would never do that again that
that that for me the evidence would have
to be higher for other people they may
have seen enough um so um but I do think
that there's an important role in the
media of clarifying what it is that we
do know and and don't at this point I
do if a second front is opened up in
terms of
Hezbollah um we could assume that that
second front does have the blessing of
Iran I don't believe that Hezbollah
would open up a second front um without
um Iran greenlighting it because they've
been so involved in all aspects of
Hezbollah but again historically the
same has not been true about Hamas I
also want to just make it very clear
that that I'm not ruling out the
possibility that Iran was involved in
this attack that that it did help Hamas
more than its traditional Baseline
levels um I'm just saying that I would
like to even to see even more evidence
along those lines drawing the
conclusion one thing that I'm curious
about is you are saying if Hezbollah
opens up a northern front um you know
then then we have a little bit more
evidence uh to substantiate this idea of
Iran being involved
with the fighting that's currently going
on on the Northern front do you sort of
characterize that as like not quite you
know it's more sort of routine something
that happens fairly frequently where the
Iron Dome intercepts some amount of
Hezbollah activity but that that just
sort of hasn't um gotten to the point
where we really consider that to be a
northern front opened up or how do you
look at that because there have been
some reports of activity there no no no
I I would say a northern front has not
been opened up um in
close to Israel's border to the north of
it there there there are other militant
groups and they sometimes um you know
commit attacks and there might even be
some Hezbollah members um who commit
some small attacks um it's basically a
communication strategy uh among these
agreed groups and Israel Israel will
respond um sometimes in a proportional
way it it's basically a way for them to
talk to each other um through violence
but when I'm talking about when I'm
talking about opening up a second front
there will be no doubt I'm talking about
taking advantage of tens of thousands of
these Rockets um really uh negatively
impacting um you know large numbers of
Israeli civilians uh if nasrala really
opens up and basically doesn't hold his
military power in in reserve a an
authorization like that by nsta I
believe would require um Iranian consent
that makes sense the parallel that I
would draw because I know a little bit
less about the part of the world that we
are talking about right now but I do
know a fair bit about China and Taiwan
is you know we see a lot of news reports
when Chinese jets fly into the taiwan's
air defense identification Zone um and
so frequently there are these very
sensationalist sort of breathless
reports of like oh my God is China
invading Taiwan is this finally it and
in fact some number of um you know
airspace encroachment is actually pretty
routine uh it's not to say that Taiwan
welcomes that or enjoys it but it is
just to say that for people un for the
uninitiated who don't follow uh Chinese
Taiwanese relations very closely that
can look very alarming but in fact is
actually a somewhat routine thing so it
seems like you're drawing that careful
Distinction on the Northern front too I
just wanted to make the other thing is
that when we're dealing with militant
groups um a common um you know thing to
happen is that there could be some sort
of a principal agent problem where uh
you know lower level members like you
know lowlevel operatives could act in
ways that don't necessarily have the
blessing um of the principal of the
leader you know um so what we're looking
at what we've seen so far is basically
relatively small amounts of violence but
I'm talking about the amounts violence
which would require um nasala to
essentially declare war um on Israel
that would involve Iran more so but then
the next question everybody wants to
know of course is just moving this along
is what should the US you know response
be hey thanks for watching that clip
from our conversation with Max Abrams
about hamas's attack on Israel for
another clip click here for the full
conversation click here